boo lay cap podcast bullet cat show
special guest in here my guy gaida is
here what's the deal kev what's up man
i'm just golden bro
happy to be here of course um first of
all congrats
you've been in the game for so long um
and now this tv show is like
just turned into a phenomenon and that
now you're like
you know you've been doing the music
thing forever but now it's like
how people reckon you're a very
recognizable dude these days with this
tv show man
shout out to dave that's wow man yeah
dave brand new
season two every day i'll be thinking
about it like man
i'm really on tv and the show with my
boy ld like it's crazy man
i never thought about being an actor you
know what i'm saying now i gotta
hold this title over my head because my
whole dream and passion was to be
a rapper rapper of course which you
still are obviously
but you know it's crazy because little
dickie he wanted to use rap and music so
he could be a comedian tv star
creative you know and now i'm in this
position and now you're using the
the tv [ __ ] to help feel the rap [ __ ]
yeah the fuel my dreams you know what
i'm saying never give up baby
yeah um for people who don't know like
like where are you from
oh me i'm from l.a central west coast so
like you would had the whole
because someone had told me that you
were like around like
tiger like early oh yeah yeah yeah like
2006 or ged
it's still ged still yeah so you got the
i got i see you got the ged chain oh
yeah i just
brought it to life i'm still pushing it
man you know it's my brand
getting every dollar grind every day
getting educated daily you know what i'm
saying so kind of give us like some of
the roots of like uh
your like hip-hop roots like in it out
here in la because i do remember i
remember the ged [ __ ] was also school
what q was around yeah schoolboy q
you know what i mean djsb we've been
rocking
uh since 2006. but basically you know
i linked up with them probably like 2006
2007.
you know we all believed in tiger was
pushing him because you know it was
undeniable talent you know
was that that was like when like travis
mccoy was around his school it wasn't
like driving mccoy related to tiger or
something
oh yeah but to keep it a buck though
that was just a marketing plot they're
not even really related
okay okay okay yeah you know what i'm
saying but because at the time travie
was scorching
it like it is what it is though like
that was just the first half of our
lives you know what i'm saying
all of us you know that gave us a jump
start and i i miss those times and i
think about those times and how they
uh groomed me for the position that i'm
in now like just to be on tour with gym
class
heroes fall out boy lil wayne and to be
with my homies from the block and stuff
like that it was just like
it was a great feeling but i learned a
lot since then so that was a blessing
yeah i mean if you think about like tyga
q
yourself i mean to look back on like how
special of an
assortment of of people i just like the
fact that we
all own you know that's what i'm saying
no it's just everybody's on
you know what i'm saying even if we not
together i could just stand over here
and just feel good like yeah cue doing
this thing you know what i'm saying t
doing this thing you know i'm saying
it's just it's just a great feeling to
know that we blossom into the men and
the artists that we are you know
it's cool and ged was your thing uh it's
all of our things
but i'm the one that started it i ain't
gonna lie look i'm still pushing it
right
right right look you know what i'm
saying 15 years later yeah 15 years
later i'm still holding it down i still
got the ged merch still
pushing it every day because this is
forever to me like when i started this
forever i can't run from the tattoo on
my face you know what i'm saying i can't
never acknowledge
not acknowledge what's something that i
believe in you know right and i'm
pushing it every day because it's just a
good mindset like
getting educated daily grind every day
getting every dollar it's just the
that's the greatest thing that you need
to make so you originally like everybody
was like okay tigers tiger's kind of our
way in the game yeah
for sure it was like nearly in the same
lunatics bro yeah it was like he was the
nelly we was the same lunatics
let's go you feel me like kick dorian
for us that's what he did
and he kicked the door in that's how i
was able to get the lil wayne songs i
was able to
travel the world go to japan you know
learn about the whole music industry
when he signed his first record dude i
was at the table right there with the
lawyer sitting there so
i was soaking up games this was the co
the coconut type yeah yeah
yeah and and all of that was just growth
and learning you know what i'm saying
because
none of those things that we did i don't
regret none of it you know
it panned out beautiful for all of us
for sure
for sure no 100 yeah no i mean i think
you know because i remember back then
when when tiger first came out everybody
was kind of like
there was this this buzz about him being
like the
guy who could hang with lil wayne from
the west coast on young money yeah it
was crazy dude you gotta think about it
we from the west coast you know what i'm
saying
we on tupac the game you know what i'm
saying the world west coast flavor
so for us to like transition into being
one of the biggest rappers in the world
it was just a great feeling because
everybody knew wayne was popping and
i'm the one that was telling t like yo
man let's let's do this bro send all
your music to wayne bro you need to
eat a hottest right now bro like go and
you guys were on the road with
gym class heroes fall out boy and little
wayne was that the tour no that wasn't
the tour
but us being on tour with fall out boy
and gym class heroes
that's a hell of a tour back then it led
to the
being in the same places as well right
right right right lil wayne 2008 vmt
uh mtv vma right it was supposed to be
fall out boy
uh lil wayne and like i think it was a
t-pain or somebody was supposed to
perform sounds about right for that for
that
yeah but i don't think t-pain could
perform because he was in the suite at
the palms with
kanye doing that other song what's that
good life yeah they was doing that song
so they was like damn we needed somebody
else to fill in t-pain or kanye spot i
think for the song that was so
it was just like yo tiger go that's your
moment and that's how they get wow
they really did that song too it was
dope it's called arms race i still
remember it like it was just i remember
that song
yeah it was crazy man like those was the
days that made me feel like
you're really soaking up and learning
man so that's why everything that comes
my way i'll be feeling so well prepared
like even sitting right here with you
i'm just so well prepared
you know what i mean like yeah it's
crazy because being around like uh you
know
fallout boy at that time is the biggest
band gym class heroes probably the
hottest band
oh yeah for sure uh i still talk to
travis man yeah you got a new song too
called spoon full of cinnamon he's a
[ __ ] legend yeah legend dude if it
wasn't for him i wouldn't have my lip
pierced
i wouldn't you know they had a song
called dress they had a song called
pilmatic
uh oh i love that yeah
jim class heroes had some [ __ ] before
they popped my favorite song was
viva the white girl yeah yes now gym
class heroes had some [ __ ] but
it's crazy because you obviously coming
from south central and then
kind of cutting your teeth in in the
game like around like
the other side of the music biz not not
necessarily the rap [ __ ] but kind of
being on the road seeing
what it's like to you know it made me
realize and i learned that
all your money comes from torrent
because
you got to break so much down with the
label the manager to break even
your crew and all that yeah but when
you're on tour that's when you really
eat you know what i mean you could go
out there
get a real bag you could push your merch
and stuff and you know people might take
a percentage of that but when you tour a
lot that's where a lot of your money
coming from so
when i learned that i'm like man i love
being on the road because it would be
dates where
i mean it'll be tourists where people on
the road for like four or five months
they don't do that no more
no not no more they don't drop no album
be on the road for four or five months
so
it made me appreciate that yeah even
just like just seeing the game from like
the alternative rock
perspective had to be different you know
like give you like a different like
a pro because you know we we're we're so
used to like coming up in the hip-hop
game there's the way you do it and
that's just kind of it is what it is but
like there's a whole other world of
music you know what i'm saying yeah but
it's crazy how those worlds
they do combine the fans the fans meet
you know the whole emo
and the whole you know i'm saying now
you should hear it in a lot of music
yeah now you hear like
the trippy reds of the world the exes of
the world and it's like yeah yeah it's
like every
all these genres are kind of just coming
together juice world juice
100 you know what i'm saying 100 so how
did you
get go from the so the ged thing was
obviously
uh it obviously didn't last long um what
was kind of like the
the the what happened with that where
like everybody went their own separate
ways
what exactly happened there we just grew
apart you know like
once tiger stopped working with the
people that he was working with on his
coconut juice deal he
transitioned over to young money and
stuff and it wasn't room for everybody
over there you know what i'm saying
cash money is cash money they got what
they got going on they believed in tiger
and we was just happy
and people come along you know what i'm
saying so i was grateful for even just
going over there
standing in the studio traveling and
getting songs and features out of wayne
and stuff
but i didn't have no business set up you
know i mean i wasn't over there to be
like hey
sign me too right right that type of
dude you know i was just happy to be in
the room and
after that it was just like everything
just started fizzling out you know tiger
just started
doing his own thing you know what i mean
what's q doing at this this time oh cue
working on that album he in there right
now
oh tde i'm really no no i'm not i mean
like during this
time oh during this time yeah what's
what's what's happening with q during oh
he was just banging out records you know
and actually he was going through a lot
of
real stuff like schoolboy q really went
to jail until he went to jail for like
six months or something right he was in
jail for a cool minute he was one of my
favorite artists we went to go visit him
and stuff i remember we went to county
jail put money on his books but
q was being killed you know what i mean
he was finding himself he was working on
music trying to perfect his craft
and then he linked up with tde and it
was over over yeah it's crazy because
he's one of my favorite artists and like
i remember my brain was broken a bit
when i found out that he was a part of
tiger's crew i was like what what oh
yeah
it's just it's real man it's real all
this is like fun facts you could really
go look this stuff up you know what i
mean
so what led to you because i met you in
2014
yeah with little dickie um this was his
first tour i think a professional rapper
tour no no no no no this was before that
this was uh
this was before save that money this was
before all that this was like uh
he had the hat that said you guys have
the hats you guys gave me a hat that
said like a little dick on it or
something i don't know what he said
[ __ ] yeah yeah and i was like i
don't know if i'm gonna wear this but
you know
somebody will that i know but uh but it
was before save that money and it was
like um
you know i felt like at the time his
youtube [ __ ] had really just started to
kind of pop off but like
um i met you you were with him then
which was like really in the beginning
so how did you guys like end up linking
up was it similar to the tv show because
the tv show was [ __ ]
awesome it was definitely similar you
know like i said i had a um
time in a music career right working on
stuff with tiger and everything and he
had a manager that was managing him
so he reached out to me one day when i
was doing bad you know i'm saying i'm
down bad on the block i remember like it
was yesterday
i got a text message from ant he like yo
i got this new artist i'm working with
i'm managing him he's like i want you to
work with him you know i'm saying he did
no concerts yet right and i want you to
bring that swag out of him you know i'm
saying that and then i just linked up
with him
at a studio in santa monica it's crazy
because i was gandering out the gate
you know i come from the rap world so
i'm like building my image in my brand
even though i had nothing i still had
the the dream and the vision
of course i pull up with a fake
cameraman fake personal assistant you
know i'm walking in the building feeling
good you know what i'm saying
and he didn't like me at first he
thought like oh man let's do this too
much
but i love this music out the gate i
always thought he was talented knew he
was a genius instantly you know what i'm
saying knew he had bars
because luka you know been around yeah i
was able to see the talent in him
fast and then after the meeting
he became cool but he told me straight
up like man at first he was a little bit
too much but he understood
that like yo that's what you need in a
rap game you got to put on
it's a show you feel me so it all worked
out man and now we don't season two dave
it's crazy
yo no it's crazy because like i think it
also like you were there like
because i think there was like a weird
period of dicky's career where like
people weren't really taking him serious
as a rapper oh yeah sure and then he had
a couple of those freestyles that were
[ __ ] insane but then like
he started to make like real records you
know because i always like when i would
tell people about little dicky i would
be like yo
you got to watch the video to get it
like or the early stuff
you know like you're like yo you got to
see the video like you
if you just listen to the song you might
be like what the [ __ ] is this
but if you see the video it brings it's
a whole different [ __ ]
thing it's you gotta see the visual um
but i think that like save that money
was like
such a well well executed idea and at
the timing of like
having rich homie quan at the time and
oh yeah it was like it was just like a
perfect storm like
this is a real [ __ ] record like this
guy can make real records but like
um like you've been around dickie from
the jump like
what was the for you like when did you
realize like oh [ __ ]
there's like uh this guy can like be
here forever type [ __ ] was it right away
or was there like a moment that happened
like
uh after the tim westwood freestyle yeah
that [ __ ] was crazy
after the ten westwood freestyle like
just to be in the building just to see
it because
like we in the rap game so this is worse
so this is hip hop like
all the like when people make songs for
the radio and you know like okay when
they specifically say oh this is going
to be the hit
i love all that too but i love like the
raw moments you know what i'm saying so
when i seen him do that at tim westwood
and how he killed it i'm like man
this is what the game needs you know
what i'm saying people like to laugh and
you know do the videos and stuff but i
like the fact that he actually has
bars like i could say yo ld can spit
with the best of them
right right i feel comfortable about it
you know what i mean because i'm old
school you know
like so it mean a lot to me just to see
him be able to shred the mic like that
what was it has it been like because you
know at the end because no song or
plaque makes me feel like oh
it's the it's the little moments like
when i get to see him put together his
songs
no i mean talk about like for you like
because you know you're kind of you've
been on the road with him this whole
time you've kind of been like
where do you see those years where you
see little dickey you see get it
period right so being somebody who's who
came from having your own crew
ged and obviously you know the chops
that you had in hip hop was it kind of
like
was it easy or difficult to kind of kick
back and like play your position for a
little bit because that's obviously
paying off
oh yeah definitely uh first it was you
know it took a few adjustments you know
i had to get you started little corny
jokes and all that right
right right but at the same time it's
just like
yeah i got a crew but do my crew really
love it
you feel me you know what i'm saying so
it makes me feel different like it made
me feel like okay i got this one
man there's one friend who makes me feel
like the world is mine you know what i'm
saying it makes me feel good and i know
that it's coming from a genuine place
you know what i'm saying like
when my boy got shot six times dickie
sent food to the hospital you know what
i'm saying and it makes me feel great
like this is a really great person on
and off camera
and that's just a great thing to know
that he's a real friend i want to rewind
a little bit you said that you
showed up to the studio and you had a
fake cameraman a great person
a fake personal assistant give me some
back
how does that okay how do you hire a
fake camera man because there's
obviously a camera
yes there's definitely a camera but at
the same time what's your thought
process to fight
to to to hire in the fake crew is it to
like show people like yo i'm hot [ __ ]
yeah that that that is that right there
yeah image
and then number two it's about creating
content i'm always going to be
documenting
what i'm doing and then it's just about
gander and i'm like okay
look shorty you believe in me right you
might as well come along on this mission
hold my phone or something
yeah make me look cooler make me look
bossed up yeah and then i got my camera
man who's
i don't know he was not to discredit i
say fake cameraman because it's earlier
stages right right wherever
you just get the camera you don't know
how to focus right right so
it was just helping and building and
bringing people along
my journey that's all you think like
that's still important
because i i know that you know once upon
a time that was very important like
you know i have good friends of mine who
would
go out of their way to quote unquote
fake it till they make it
right right and i think that there was a
point in time and i'm not i don't know
if it's still
important but i know that there was a
point in time that was very important
because you only get one impression on
somebody
oh yeah it dude it's still important you
know because
people got a brand you know what i'm
saying people want to dream you know
what i'm saying
and it's called manifestation really the
whole fake it till you make it thing is
really just a
manifestation tactic and just preparing
yourself for the future
and then you can make it and still be
faking it you know what i'm saying
there's people like
i ain't going to say no names but they
act like they're on a private jet but
they're really on a commercial flight
shout out to bow wow yeah
i mean we all know it was about listen
the bow wow challenge listen i don't got
no problems with nobody of course
but he did do that he didn't do that
it's well documented
but it's just like man you know people
still do it right
right right i see people with a lot of
money making stuff bigger than what it
really
is you know what i mean but it's just a
rap game you know people want to be
entertained it's just entertaining hey
interrupting the interview
to tell you about our good friends at
odd socks now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying
ooh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssoxofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks
these are the outsiders you know what
i'm saying they got spongebob
they got cheech and chong listen
breaking bad
godfather whatever you need they got it
and now they have underwear
that's right you can get your odd socks
underwear the boxer briefs are the best
underwear that you could ever fit on
your ass
trust me when i tell you these are
chucky draws
what you know about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword
bootleg kev at checkout and you'll save
20 off of
of your order underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
have it check out save 20
one of the like most like relatable
things on the on the first season of the
show that i
i was like this is so spot on was the yg
feature part oh yeah shout out to homie
yg man
that [ __ ] happens so often in hip-hop
where you'll
you'll cash someone out for a feature
it's probably not going to get cleared
by the major label they're never going
to push it or reply they're never going
to push it they're never going to repost
it and it is going to be
a [ __ ] mission to actually get the
stems and the verse and
that was like the most like i was like
this is some real ass [ __ ] right the
whole the whole show was so
real like it's just like coming up as
like a artist like but like that
specific was that like something that
actually happened like something similar
to that that actually happened
yeah definitely man because i know he
cashed out kwon and he cashed out fetty
for that song because i remember he told
me
yeah definitely man stuff didn't happen
to a lot of artists in the game you know
what i'm saying
gucci ran off on french with five
thousand
but did something like that happen to
dicky where there was like like he like
he cashed somebody out it was like a
little bit harder to get get
i think so but i don't know like the
exact details but
it'd be a lot of stuff going on behind
the scenes you know and
you got to deal with a lot of the stuff
when you're on this path because
everybody know that music industry
is like street spread it kind of is
man i'm saying a lot of janky stuff
going on were you uh how instrument
are you as far as just like bringing
ideas to the table for the tv show
i'm a consultant on there if you read
the credits at the end and say gator
actor gated consultant like
i chime in i go to the writer sessions
they ask me certain scenarios how i was
saying because it was so authentic
it was it just felt like so like i never
say what's on the paper
man in the script i always go off i got
the green light to do that from fx and
from dave
it's like it's like it does a really
good job of like the show is if you have
nothing
like no knowledge of the music industry
and you're just watching a comedy it's
[ __ ] hilarious but if you know you
know [ __ ]
it's like oh this is like spot on like
this is how it is
i just like that we got jokes for both
audiences you know i'm saying 100
black people we got that you know i'm
saying for the white people we got that
you know what i'm saying we bring it
together that's what i really like you
know we got the best of both worlds and
you guys put a d
on tv which is amazing shout out my
[ __ ] a.d man
i wonder if his teeth got the separate
like screen actors guild of war check
[Music]
i've been i've been clowning 80s teeth
since he got him he knows
he got that that corn on the cob eaters
right there [ __ ] tear down some
corn some elote you got that new money i
was thinking about knocking my [ __ ] out
no you're good man yeah no you're good
were you did you ever have any acting
experience
no i never had no acting experience i
never had any acting classes or anything
like that
you're pretty much yourself though right
yeah i play myself a heightened version
of myself right
right i'm not that energetic right right
but i am always hyped sometimes because
i'm always feeling good like what's not
to feel good about we wake up every day
breathing is a privilege chase your
dreams get money let's go you know what
i'm saying so i'll be feeling good
um has there been give me give me a
story where you because
because dave's not a smoker right oh
yeah yeah they smoke weed
but he just don't smoke weed after
before 6 p.m
you know what i'm saying he's got to be
after he smoked like a uh like he in
corporate america
well the first the first episode of
season two was so funny because like
the whole entire weed aspect where you
got the weed in the background
and is that really happening man yeah so
that actually happened give us that
story it was in canada though like
i was uh smoking out there in canada you
know i get the blood everywhere and
it was time to go to the uh to the
airport so i dumped all the wheat or
whatever the case may be
but i still have some crumbs in my
passport so i go through the
security check-in they checking me they
check my backpack i'm like oh i'm good
man i ain't got no weed no nothing
and let me let behold they pull out my
passport
and it's like crumbs like probably like
dude literally like
when i say crumbs yeah crumbs right
right like you couldn't like
yeah crumbs right so they like oh he got
weed so
they hold up the whole line they pull me
to the side they take me in the cell
talking about you gonna have to stay the
tuesday
y'all gonna miss your flight but this is
the crazy trip though
it went from all of that from you got to
see the council on tuesday
and then they backpedaled all the way
once they found out i was with lil dicky
they like oh
you were him y'all got a concert all
right well that's what we gonna do
i know we made y'all miss our flight but
we're gonna book y'all the hotel and you
know what i'm saying y'all could stay
wait that part they did that yeah the
hotel did that i mean the airport did
that the airport did that oh yeah it was
crazy man like
it went from the flight is canceled
y'all y'all
making the flight yeah we're sorry
literally i was in a cell bro i'm in a
cell
like uh at the airport dj esco like i
was in dubai
oh my god i was in a cell bro i'm in
there like damn i really gotta talk to
the council like
who is the council like they were
supposed to be on the phone with the
judge like
trying to set up the case already but
before all that happened they figured it
out found out little dickie had a
festival in canada
and then like two of the security guards
was fans so they let me go
wow so that actually did happen it
really happened
that's crazy crazy man and so talk about
your music man because i know that
you know like we said earlier you kind
of now you have a lot of eyes on you and
it's kind of crazy how like you and
dickie's like uh
roles have reversed a bit like like you
said he used music to get like because
anytime you'd ever talk to him he was
always like i want to have my own sitcom
i want to write for tv shows i want to
do all this
and you always had the hip-hop dream
yeah and now that you're on the show
it's like one hand washes the other yeah
it's such a blessing man
and that's where we bounce off each
other at you know i mean we both our
worlds collide and just like hey
i know you want to do this i want to do
that and he supports me you know i'm
saying like
i got new music coming out got a song
called checkup coming out and
i can't wait to drop it video all that
the video's got to be crazy though
because you're coming from
that wheelhouse where the the visuals
have to be insane oh yeah definitely man
we
definitely going left it's not gonna be
a regular music video you know what i'm
saying we definitely gonna laugh it's
gonna be the
right direction are you gonna be doing
any other acting oh yeah for sure i just
wrapped the uh
short film origin brizza yeah wu-tang
queen
tang you know what i'm saying shout out
to blue you know what i mean but i did a
movie with him
alexis pappas and jeremy i think it's
i don't want to mess up his last name
but it's alexis is a fiancee he's a
director too fire but it's a dope movie
man i've been grinding man man
you knocking out auditions my agent's
always sending me scripts
dude it's i mean [ __ ] you wouldn't think
that you've never acted before
watching the show because i always knew
that i wanted to be in front of the
camera and like be a star like if i want
to be a rapper it's like you got to know
how to feel comfortable in front of the
camera you got to know how to be able to
entertain yourself you always
look to look the part yeah man like i
come from that man like i said
when you're around lil wayne every day
and you [ __ ] like
running with your homies and you trying
to do what you do it's like you're gonna
pick up some sauce some drip
let me ask you this being on the road
with dickie all those years
he what are the dicky groupies like
like because i can only imagine like how
much of the
it's crazy man cuz he doesn't seem like
the type of person to partake in a lot
of that activity
definitely not like but it's crazy you
may or may not have at a certain point
in time in your life
particularly you've been the guy to you
know maybe pick up some of that slime
yeah
definitely so so what yeah what what is
that like the groupies on the road for
ld are crazy like it'll be like
a guy will walk up and be like yo my
sister suck your dick if you let her
backstage and it's just like
wow like that the stuff that you'd be
seeing in the show really you know i'm
saying it'd be it'd be crazy like did
you say
where's your sister nah she's standing
right there because that's weird the
dude
the sister literally be right next to
the brother like all that type of stuff
be happening
but you know dickie's such a like a
classy guy he's a nice guy he don't even
be into the group he's like when the
groupies be rushing him and stuff he'd
be like ill gross she has herpes oh my
god this isn't one chance that i might
catch this like you know he's so
cautious and he's so focused on his
dream that
he ain't even worried about the uh dude
i remember we were in tampa
and you guys did uh wild splash our
radio show
in 2000 was we in the tent like outside
on the street
no but we were in uh it was right off
clearwater beach the water was still
left
and uh this was uh who else was on the
show it was
dicky i think it might have been
i remember meek mill was on the show it
was
but what's crazy is it was either the
night before or the night of
the show like the station had this deal
with this club club sky in
ebor city in tampa which was like the
most hoodest club in the [ __ ] city
right
and they had dickie host and it was so
hilarious and random to see him in that
setting
because because that's not his vibe
whatsoever but he
bro he performed at club sky and had all
these [ __ ] bbws twerking on him and
he just loved like
it was hilarious dude it was like i got
i hope you guys had a camera guy that
day because that was like one of those
days where it was like i was like yo
this is crazy
like this little yeah man that's what
people love about him too because
you know when he come in the building
it's like okay he's going to be making
people
laugh and feel good you know it's always
walking in the arms you know what i'm
saying right all right
and then you we go to it be loved are
you working on an album or are you just
doing singles
i'm dropping a single but i'm definitely
working on an album ep whatever you want
to call it nowadays but i got a
full-length project body of work coming
out
what what's your relationship like with
q and tiger these days i'm i'm still
cool with you me and q i see him all the
time he was probably like
quite as kept the funniest [ __ ]
in hip-hop oh he always cracking jokes
on people
he is an absolute maniac he always yeah
him and freddie gibbs
are so [ __ ] funny and people wouldn't
really know it unless you like really
know them but q is an
absolute hoe like he could he he should
be on tv
yeah he he a good person man cute he's
the best person
and he's a hell of a golfer randomly oh
yeah that's crazy man i can't wait till
i'm able to chill on the golf course
so you and q are still tight oh we're
not tight but you guys still totally
cool yeah
i see him all the time it's always love
and everything but you know tiger's
just tiger tiger's just talking man he
doing he doing his thing
he's only fans pimping too which is
amazing i didn't know that he's
necessary
hey man i ain't mad at it he's got his
only fan's agency and i heard he's
keeping a nice cut
probably running up the figures like
crazy you know what i'm saying but is it
focused on
how did you get your name gata because i
always think of the name gaeda as will
ferrell's pimp name in the other guys
i'll be getting a lot of those memes
people always be tweeting me uh that
scene with yeah stuff when he dressed up
like a pimp right right but i got the
name from my uncles because they're from
the south
and you know it used to be like a myth
that they used to be like alligator
wrestlers so they used to be called the
gator boys
oh yeah i always hear that from my
family so i just was like you want to
call myself gator boy
and i used to actually spell the
g-a-t-o-r but i changed it to g-a-t-a
because i want to be a rapper be cooler
and i changed the meaning to going
against the average
that's what g-a-t stan g-a-t-a stands
for okay what is there
do you think that season two is better
than season one
from uh just just if from from uh to be
honest with you i'm not even gonna
answer that because honestly i haven't
even seen all season two but i know it's
dope though
i know it's better i know it's great
it's great it's a great body of work but
i want to
see it all yeah because i heard it's
amazing though no yeah like i haven't
seen every episode
because you're pretty much in all the
episodes right one through ten yeah i
mean i love season one
season one is [ __ ] classic man yes
either one is classic man
put us on the map that's all we back i
was just saying did you have any idea
like
when i saw that you know it got
announced that he was doing a show like
i knew
i was like dude if they just let him do
him it's going to be crazy right but
like you never know what some of these
corporations and
you know create but but did you guys
like know like did you
have a feeling like while you guys are
filming it like this is going to be some
special [ __ ]
i knew it was gonna be special but
honestly i didn't think it would be this
like
where it's at now you know i always
believed but i was just like you know
you never know
until it happens you know so i just had
a lot of anxiety built up until it came
out
i was just like i can't wait to see what
it's like and now that i see what it's
like it's like man
yeah because i think that there's like a
huge uh
[Music]
there's like a it's missing in tv right
now i can't think of a comedy that i
[ __ ] with this
on tv besides dave like a comedy oh man
thank you man
no like like i [ __ ] with kirby
enthusiasm but larry david puts out a
[ __ ] season like once every five
years
dr drake style yeah and then like
outside of that like
sitcoms are all trash like they're all
corny as [ __ ] there's like no more
seinfeld that's like
the go-to like dave is like i think it's
like a show that is needed you know like
it's always in sunny in philadelphia i
don't even think that shit's on anymore
it's all new rick and morty by the way
no rick and morty's fire now rick and
morty's good i just meant like some live
action [ __ ] but i think like you guys
can do this [ __ ] for as long as you want
man hey speak it into existence man
cause that'll be dope i'm on tv until
i'm like 80
right right right was there any ideas um
that
almost made season one that ended up not
making it or like some stuff you guys
shot that ended up like getting scrapped
that you thought
oh yeah i'm pretty sure because dickie
every day he plotting and jotting that's
what i like to call it he always taking
notes
right so he got like a long list of
notes in his phone
every funny moment every serious moment
every moment he's just always
paying attention and he know he needs
content so i'm pretty sure it's a lot of
stuff that got left out
and you so you your new song once is
video coming out too
yeah video coming out too well this is
well i was asked to hold this interview
until the song comes out so let's say
the song is out
okay sounds out the song is [ __ ] out
let's go check up
check up go get the uh and when is the
video coming out right after is the
video already shot is the video already
out
it's in the canvas okay okay but uh the
song
is out crazy check up going nuts go get
it on spotify apple music everywhere
i really appreciate everybody for doing
that for me go log in i'm back
i mean never left but i've been working
on this acting yeah you'll be killing it
on the acting and it's dope too because
like i think like
la hip-hop is in a very uh special place
right now
i feel like i feel like the energy in la
is
crazy it's it's probably the best it's
been and i mean i don't even know it's
been a long time since i felt
this much just camaraderie coming out of
the city
so many dope young artists that are all
doing their own thing at the same time
you know who your favorite new west
coast artist i mean i obviously love
blast
yeah that's going crazy i love
[Music]
one take jay's dope fire uh that kid
ramble
is [ __ ] hard oh yeah that ruth chris
freestyle go nuts
he's crazy yeah i'm not like he's like a
evolution of like draco yeah but like
he does i don't know if he like he he'd
be giving me e5 sometimes yeah
like real life the way he just talks
he'd be saying some dumb stuff
he'd just be saying the illest [ __ ] just
talking yeah yeah i'm like this [ __ ]
guy's an
alien i've never heard nobody like i
have this raw talent man
super raw i was like it's like to the
point like he like one of those rappers
where i'll be feeling like
so he can entertain the whole like if he
went to jail he could entertain the
whole jail
well that was cool about him is i i
don't think anyone's ever uh
i don't i think i'm always like yo
what's different that what that dude's
doing is different i don't think people
can say like they've heard some [ __ ]
like him before where he's literally
just sounds like he's like
just talking to you on the phone but
it's just sounds fly interesting
man a lot of a lot of them catch us
doing that like that yeah draco when
draco came up here we did a freestyle
with draco and his brother ralphie
and the same thing with draco draco
literally just got on the mic and just
talked yeah draco got bars
and it sounded fire yeah no draco's dope
detroit doing a lot of that too like
that whole just
[ __ ] talking at the highest level yeah
no detroit stoke shot uh babyface ray pz
i mean this guy loves detroit hip-hop
who else from detroit's dope i swear
vasa hero giovanni
yeah this guy this guy's from the bay
though so they they have like shout out
to baby
bay in detroit too they're in detroit
have a thing i love the bay man
messi marv i love messi more
don't get him started over there yay
this guy thinks magdre is the most
influential rapper of all time
oh yeah one of all time all the time i
wouldn't say all the time
you gotta just you gotta know where he
from first you gotta respect i know
where he's from
yeah from the bay from the bay yes yeah
is he the most influential from the bay
quite possibly yeah is he more
influential than e40
maybe not
i don't know yeah i see what you're
saying i don't know but
he said ever hip-hop period
he didn't mean that he didn't mean that
tupac jay-z rock him
we could go down the [ __ ] list all
right peter mcdre but relax
anyway um all right cool man well look
go go check out gato's new record it's
out he's gonna be
uh all 10 episodes of dave season two
locked in make sure y'all tap in we got
all new
new movie coming with the rizza oh yeah
not an artist that's the name is he in
the movie acting or is he a director
movie acting
that's what made me feel good like i'm
gonna be on screen with a legend you
know what i'm saying there's a bunch of
beautiful actors in there too what was
that like like working with the wrestler
was he cool
man he was giving me some great gems man
he was you know i'm saying it was dope
like at first i was just like damn okay
i'm working with rizzo but just in our
down time when he was talking to me
he want to see a young man do well you
know he's uh yeah man
anytime somebody like that at that level
could just sit down and give you gyms
you gotta appreciate that i mean and
then he was directing it as well no he
was just acting oh he was just
accidental acting in it yeah
versus that guy the leader were you like
a wu-tang fan growing up
yeah definitely casuals everything
around me cream all that i love all that
man
there it is i'm a hip-hop junkie bro hey
look
is there gonna be some uh do you have
any any features that you have tucked
right now
i got something but i'll rather wait for
people to see it okay all unfolds you
know what i mean
well there it is gator man appreciate
you for pulling up boo lakehead podcast
check them out my man